how's it going bros my name is beautify
Oh No
welcome back to mr. Fattah I have a
frickin cross-domain in church and I
found a wooden stake so you better
better back out
Oh oops I freaking demon spawns all
right we're gonna go in here hello
okay back up how does Satan smack that
OH
I kept smacking on the grass stop
driving there we go the dog-shaped gun
gotcha dog-shaped gun of justice huh on
uzuki the game is not that scary but
it's the book uh-huh it's a [ __ ]
soundless give it okay back up Swiss on
Sarge
sod yes no more friends what are your
friends now [ __ ] okay don't come on
right on up
oh that's where to get you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what am I now wait am i back
here back up good power-ups Satan power
god I'm a Valka yes so you get your
little [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] okay there should be a key
here somewhere guys a wooden stake in
Senna lovely what is the what gimme a
[ __ ] key or something please be a key
in here ammunition for my revolver
that's fan-fucking-tastic wait what ah
you brought your fan
that's what oh you're like mr. shy
are you summoning this demon part ups
now I would never
oh you better not all right it's clearly
not here so we got to go downstairs got
to go down got to go down got to go down
gotta go down on the girl I'm just
kidding hmm all right let's just take it
real easy just slide down those [ __ ]
stairs you don't have fruit says when
you go down the stairs for whatever
reason Oh follow the green right light I
remember okay
the priest priest oh let's follow the
green light how I look safe but ah I
should have spoken Japanese - that guy
hurt 360 hurt all right
anyone want to bring it oh all right
just write that BAM right in your face
oh you want to speak chopped knees smack
that job oh you are obviously not as
good as Japanese as me chop chop chop
hahahaha that's what you get hello
oh just sweet meet him health packs
sweet huh uh-huh
[ __ ] me do something do something do
something [ __ ] everything is splashes
splash ah [ __ ] I'm out of splashes bash
that was not worth it god dammit why do
I waste my splashes was it in here I
don't [ __ ] remember ah power of Satan
back off
works every time uh what's the point of
this place and it was green here it's
gotta be secret in here come on buddy
come on buddy give me your secret mr.
Xiaomi I don't know shut up
you never know back off back off back
off I will show you my fist mag dad Oh
punch punch punch punch punch punch
punch punch punch all right all right
the green light [ __ ] light where's
Orca I missed that son of a [ __ ] BAM
Denine [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me dogs oh
not not bestiality I just said [ __ ] me
and then dogs in the same sentence that
it I'm necessarily don't get any ideas
you [ __ ] disgusting perverts all
right
holy [ __ ] ah okay let's see you reload
this [ __ ] I'm lesbian ah [ __ ] dogs stop
raping a doctor rape ignite it hurts
come back up back up back up back up huh
back up but ah what's killing me all
your [ __ ] sneaky [ __ ] came from
behind okay that took like all my health
[ __ ] fantastic
alright okay he was yes what took you so
long
well you know right um I don't know
though receiving this [ __ ] ah okay huh
what the hell are you watch what you're
doing what were you two doing in there
there's a bad oh I don't even want to
know you disgusting you're disgusting
a woman with the demons dogs all right
let's check the last rooms Wow ah watch
out girl
I'll handle this
yes I got you the first time Boop
BAM just deny her goodnight then I can
die denied denied you're all [ __ ] the
night day night I [ __ ] I don't even know
why I went here [ __ ] point lash
alright I suck with it why did they
sleep here seriously I don't get how you
doing huh what day it
why don't you down there stupid woman I
can remember all right we're going in
here come on slowpoke
alright Jesus cry all right full of the
green light that's what he said what's
this [ __ ] do it
hello penny I heard you got scared shut
up mr. Sher don't you be such a weakling
you can kick you have legs
I booked all right from the scripts of
Greenville warriors Lord of Milwaukee as
an ancient vampire flatter than the
Rhian during the claim some words many
centuries ago he is now binding his time
waiting to be record thread and brought
back to the former powers I am NOT
talking in the Martian eggs and holy
[ __ ] I've wasted my ammo I can't
yes the garrison key we found that
aren't you happy arch oh I'm sorry did I
smack your titties I like em okay let's
not smack her titties oh no she died
what uh oh no what a tragedy we will
have to load I thought I I almost didn't
know you could kill someone while he's
slapping their kitties it was hard it
was all your side okay don't be afraid I
won't slap your titties just come here I
promise come here ah hello James glad to
see you
good air Shep let's get out of here holy
[ __ ] we're all right chap Hey you're
awesome
alright I took a back Hey retail this
girl here who step in madam come here oh
all you anywhere change well then
[ __ ] do it
holy [ __ ] alright Kimmy gonna heavily
kemplay hell you I love voice actor
Emily oh all right just follow the green
light I heard something Emily yeah was
you got a real oh my gum got to be ready
for this [ __ ]
then I oh it's got to be Superman you're
not all gay bow all right bring it bring
it bring it bring you ain't got [ __ ] on
me bro
I don't even know where to go
okay let's just go come here stop bugs
[ __ ] your slop look shut up scare me
don't do debt can't you open a [ __ ]
door come on e all right why have a guy
Ptolemais you're worse than my dog
polish you Jasper still Chaplin I'll
watch your back how about you [ __ ]
join me come on you too madam come here
I won't slap your today's please how do
you ready to use I won't
aah then [ __ ] do it seriously where
Oh tonight then [ __ ] night all right
let's just find our way out of here I
guess come on you uh
the AI is too smart in this game like
come on I'll slap your balls don't make
me slap them again holy [ __ ] pissing me
off
all right let's go here I guess nope why
would they build this I'm sorry
holy [ __ ] things is the right way
[ __ ] [ __ ] no it's like smack smack yes
this is garrison we should go here not
now but later come on come on you little
[ __ ] come on I won't slap them I
promise you're [ __ ] all disgust still
Chapman I am John
alright there's a dog
stupid dog scared them alright we're
good
until you think about - [ __ ] this is
just big one big [ __ ] mess isn't it
oh [ __ ] it on him I did not go as
planned
what am I holy [ __ ] there's my lot of
rooms in this game who the you're gonna
pick up the Gunpowder I don't care am i
real all right follow me ladies I
including you kazoo
[Music]
I'm not sure if it's a good idea to go
with these people I'll just I should
just let them there honestly come at me
bro I'm not the bunny tonight huh what
was I was I was I was I was I was I all
right [ __ ] it let's just go what what
trustus your raid my mama's ah rapers
what the hell how many are you
da son son son polish stop it
Bucky oh you see that quick oh holy [ __ ]
enemy and draw my gun and I shot for my
[ __ ] sword all right no idea what's
going on you're new to me
oh I know where we are
come on buddies come I brush I'm gonna
free you [ __ ] don't worry pop up here
just get it under control
under control underneath control under
control inner control in your budget
alright it's this way actually I think
Please Please Please Miss New Jersey yes
come here you stupid as always it if
you're sure come here I'll follow you
anywhere James well then [ __ ] do it
thank you I'm out oh it's no time for
orgasm lady
all right come here you step I hate both
of you I sincerely you better have good
stuff in your packages now that sound of
perverted you better have a good stuff
in your pockets it whatever alright I
hope we can find or kena apparently
orchid responds in his kennel hopefully
we can take him with us okay yes okay
I missed you boy poof come here buddy
what are you doing staring out there
okay
come here okay oh what a bunch of
[ __ ] retards look at them holy [ __ ]
alright yes some look how many people
who have save that now even orcas go the
rest of the family is rescued heal me
watch your back
heal me heal me something for that wound
thank you give me some water you're just
gonna stand there you're just gonna
stare that without talking to me uh what
about you are you a [ __ ] statue or
what all of you why are you crying don't
cry don't you cry ah
alright I'm gonna end it a brush hope
you enjoyed that's your favorite if you
did subscribe to come erosion and I'll
see you tomorrow
Hey
I know you're busy eating
I need to go down